Fear is an emotion that has faded my mind for as long as I can remember, yet, today,
I am scared.
I cannot remember when or how I came to this land.
Mother tells me she had followed a trail from a mysterious wreckage and found me in a cave.
I was surrounded by death and darkness, yet I was the only one to survive.
This day she told me of was the last time I had ever cried.
She had seen the unfathomable abuse that plagued her family for generations, the monster of
a bear that wriggled fear throughout the food chain of this land.
Its mere presence cursing the very soil under the snow, that, here it was, that at the hands
of a mere child who said crying alone.
It was then she had decided to raise me as her own, along with my brother and sister.
She taught me strength to hunt, to survive.
I had no memories of my birth family.
I did not feel the need to search for them, or I had my family here, and they had me.
I was a bear like them, and they treated me no different.
We all shared the same love, but Mama knew it was not meant to be.
There comes a time in the bear's life where they must go out on their own, and that time
was approaching fast.
Mama knew the cops would be fine, but me, I couldn't even find them being without them.
Until one day, over the mountains, she happened upon an answer.
An answer I didn't want to accept, but one I had to.
And now, this day, the day if fear finally formed in my heart for the first time, saying
their final goodbyes, my brother went one way, my sister went another.
But there I stood, my body and mind, tempered from this land of unforgiving cold, was frozen
still.
Mother offered me her strength one last time, enough to cement the final memory of her tenderness,
my final goodbye.
She would watch over me one last time, when my journey down from the mountaintop into
the unknown of the future.
The memory of her love within me made the fear in my heart melt away, like the ice and
spring.
But she reminded me that the warmth of her love made me into a survivor.